hello hey ricky how are you so casual
just walk in during a show
do you like it or yeah does it reek of
uh a lack of professionalism well no
it's sort of like those old-fashioned
shows where someone would come in that
or the audience would clap right
it's just like a set right sinatra would
just walk on smoking
where the guy walks in with the tool
belt hey and then they're like oh
he has to pause before he delivers his
line we saw a play that in
london that um al pacino was in and he
walked out in the audience started
applauding i was going well no don't
right no no that's not al pacino
in the narrative that's being put out
for what was the play um
what was the play you don't remember it
you just went to see al pacino
al pacino american buffalo
james was concentrating was that a film
um
well not at this point it was definitely
a play i was there
i don't know if i filmed it
sometimes when jim wears his 3d glasses
he puts his hands out
to see if it's really people in front of
you sometimes i wait after the movie to
meet the actors going out
in 3d glasses it's not scary isn't it it
is he has to
he puts his little peepers on and then
the 3d glasses in front of him first 3d
movie ever saw for me was friday the
13th part three
yes with the with the red and the blue
3d glasses that's right yeah
i've never been to a 3d film back then
the glasses were not good
these these now they're plastic they was
these paper like like once you get the
cereal box well someone told me
the ones that the home video ones with
the glasses
it's a better experience than the at the
cinema
because the glasses are better like 3d
tvs
yeah yeah if you're close enough and
you're in the right angle it can be a
bet it can
it but i don't get it anywhere you have
your house around you though you can't
see i don't know why you need 3d no it's
like we don't need
it's you know what i mean it's not
what's what's happening
i avoid 3d movies i love a 3d movie if
it's an action movie i like a good legal
drama in 3d
where they slam the papers down and one
flies at you and you duck
but in the early days did they make them
like lots of pointing and yeah
i mean that if you here's like i watched
that movie that jim saw friday the 13th
part three
but the first time i saw it was on
either like vhs or dvd
and it was not in 3d and i was sitting
there watching it like
none of these shots make any sense why
is he just playing yo-yo into the
the camera thing i've ever seen what
were they throws there's one where jason
throws a spear
i think it was like you throw and i
remember seeing that in the theater and
people it was amazing
he throws it directly into the camera
but when you're watching it on dvd
you're like that adds nothing why would
they do that it's weird with effects
isn't it because
you look back and you go oh my god that
looks really hokey and awful but at the
time
did it work yes 100 i remember seeing in
the i couldn't believe it it was it was
why is that why do we why are we sort of
more and more demanding just
uh we adjust to things we we just adjust
to things
yeah we adjust well now i know that can
be done i've seen that before that i
know that that's just movie stuff
i guess i've sort of never been
impressed with car traces and special
effects and
and rubber suits and superpowers you
know what i mean yeah i've always wanted
i agree with that joking aside i would
prefer illegal drama
yeah people talking in a really
compelling
way or plotting that i could just watch
that i think that's why i like things
like you know um
i've been watching the last year i think
i've been watching nothing but like
scandic dramas like
serial killer stuff like you know the
bridge the killing
um before we die
um you know gamora it's because it's
it's
it's sort of plotting and also there's
lives at stake
but it's not it's not ridiculous it's
not right shoot them up and
i would love i would love to agree with
you because it sounds much more
intellectual
and i was about to but then i also
remembered that i've seen like the last
six fast and furious movies in theaters
and bought a ticket i've never seen one
of them
never i i know have i i mean look i'm
sure they're great for what they are
i've just never
let's go and watch some dudes in fast
cars well now they've gone
hang out just go on the motorway
[Laughter]
you watch their journey they've gone
from just like a crew of like just
regular people who drive really fast
yeah in this last one they actually had
to use their fast cars
to stop a nuclear warhead from being
launched and
ending the world that's actually a topic
because
of the shark then that's fine as long as
it's
so nine is like fast and furious with
godzilla right
i think so no it's probably gone the
completely other way nine they have to
stop a fat shaming somewhere
they're at the garage all their cars are
in the garage for the weekend because i
had a blowout so
and they're just chatting about you know
you know you know in those episodes of
a show where they haven't got an episode
so it's like people like
a best-stuff thing yeah when they talk
about things they look back like it's
like
the christmas episode and they're like
you remember our first christmas in this
apartment
yeah and it's just scenes from all the
other movies the actors are demanding
more pie
now on holiday they've got drug problems
they go
okay we just make one up they're like
look we can get the rock
for a day and a half and vin diesel's
got two days i don't know what we're
gonna do here
i've seen films when you know that
they've had that person for a day and a
half
they walk into the same room three times
do a speech and leave
it's like yeah i know here's why we get
used to things like you know
why do we want more picture a flip phone
when a flip phone cell phone was first
out it was [ __ ] amazing
but now you look at a flip phone you're
like ugh like you just get spoiled
quickly i suppose so yeah nokia's
bringing back like uh
the the phone that they had in the
matrix which was called they called it a
banana phone because there's like yellow
and it slides down it's got this curve
and nokia's bringing it back but what
was once this phone that you're like oh
[ __ ] that's the phone from the matrix
like that's the future phone
is now kind of a kitschy retro right if
you want to if you want to live
before probably the innovation
is that obviously age is faster as well
so you look at an apple product
right from a year ago and it looks like
it's from the 50s
right because it was so far ahead and
now the next one's so far ahead and out
there
right i remember those the apple macs
now they look
they look like toys yeah that were the
state of the art
even phones like i've seen people that
like you have your phone just looks like
an iphone i got this like a year and a
half ago and they're like oh
still a button on there huh you have the
one with the one button on there oh no
that's
but the thing is i i find the other
thing i get i get used to a phone i get
a new one and i go oh it hasn't got the
this one this one hasn't got the thing
for the um
that drives me [ __ ] crazy yeah so
why'd they do that because they're dicks
yeah and they want you to buy more stuff
they want you to spend a hundred fifty
dollars on blue is it
is it really that cynical cause someone
told me that they said that they when
they change the charger that makes them
a billion dollars
is it really that cynical i think
they're in the business of
planned obsolescence absolutely
making sense absolutely yes well i heard
that as a theory as well that they don't
want an everlasting light bulb
right you know they don't want it yeah
yeah of course yeah but i get that
right but surely just um making it
making it more compatible with
everything is good for everyone they
don't care about that though there
really is that thing where if now all of
a sudden you have one a charger that can
work with anything or or headphones that
work with anything they'll never sell
them again right
and everyone is planning on developing
that's a word yeah yeah i think it is
they want you to buy from them too like
just when everybody in the world has
figured out how to make this wire
they're like well that's not going to
work
on our phone anymore you have to buy the
new apple wire from the apple store like
the first iphone didn't have a flash in
the camera the iphone 4 when it came out
had no flat
and i remember being in a rage about
that they had no fl and then they put
now a flash included in the camera
so all your pictures came out like [ __ ]
because there was no flash i i think i
use
about um you know people say that people
use like 20 percent of their brain
i use about one percent of my technology
seriously
my laptop i i don't
does that have words that have microsoft
word 97 on it all right we're good
yeah i use it for the clock
you don't go online a lot you're not
online all the time i'm online all the
time but it's the same thing it's i
you know i i i don't know what i do
really i
tweet yeah but that's not like i i i
looking up information i guess i use it
like i do use google like a library
yeah like you know uh but not just
ironic because google's
i mean immensely less reliable than a
library but it can give you it can give
you the clue and then you've got to be
discerning
as opposed to just the the first website
that comes up with that word you know
so um but no i i i mean i don't
i i know it's amazing it's like the
first calculator had already beaten the
computer that put the men on the moon
what i mean
and now but um no i don't i don't i i
mean it's amazing i do love technology
and i think the internet's incredible
and you know i think it is but i don't
i never get the most out of it couldn't
it only do basic math
the original computers for nasa when the
apollo 13 went up but there was very
basic uh
method it was basically a 50 for abacus
[Laughter]
just lifting the weight they're doing
all hand calculations and writing stuff
down
it was basically like um uh the
old-fashioned
tapes wasn't it with holes in it yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it's still based on
the binary yes no yes no you know a
million times and then they'd have to
look at the thing that they came out
with
the computer to double the to ten times
the the power and all that so
they had it all it was just too big it
was just too big
that photo of 50 megabytes or five
megabytes of uh
information you ever see that like
getting onto a plane can you look that
up troy it's
a plane in like the 60s or the 50s
they're loading five
megabytes on and this is what it looked
like back then
yeah um it might have been in the 50s
and it's an image of it going
onto a plane we've looked oh yeah there
it is that's five megapixels five
megabytes
i love the contempt you have for your
listeners they
were just just looking up and showing me
a picture well you know what it inspires
them to google we get a little
kickback from google whenever they look
up something
it's because it's because they want to
hear the joy
of ricky gervais getting to look at some
of these little images five megabytes
and
these five people are on the plane
looking at it getting put up in this
cargo hall like what the [ __ ] is this
did you ever look back and for your lied
to as well though like you know you know
where you know in the 60s they said in
the 1980s no one will walk to work the
pavements will move
and all that sort of stuff and then
we'll all hover we're of hoverboards
what's up with them that's nice i look
back to what i was lied to and my mother
said someday you're going to grow
older and find a person to love you oh
that's tough
oh that's tough i know yeah but then she
looked at you and vomited
[Laughter]
threw you against the wall
and you could hear you could hear them
screaming it didn't die
it didn't die she knocked out she
grabbed him by my little fat baby legs
and knocked her out
what were you like as a baby what was
little jim like as a baby oh you don't
you have to have a bag of worms yeah i
was i was like i've always thought of
him what's that what's that film
is it um
when it's connected to the body the
little baby in the on the
total recall
we've had conversations about like where
did it all go wrong for jim and like i
mean we're talking as early as like
five maybe really what were you like as
a kid then because i'm fascinated with
you your journey
uh i was uh i was obviously intimidated
by you at first
why i loved you
but i thought if anyone is going to end
up
in the papers it's jim and he's and he
didn't you know because it was all
i mean like in as a criminal or is it
famous
things found in his basement right do
you know what i mean you know
i'm a good boy i know you were
intimidated by him
in the sense that like this guy could be
a real danger i
i think i know i don't know what i
mistook his candor
um for uh lack of morals just for the
first couple of times and i thought that
you gotta be careful that guy because
he's he's skinned someone and
he's born as a coat right i thought god
if this is the stuff he confesses
what's the stuff he's keeping quiet
right which is a which is
totally well because he was you know he
was telling everything which is great
but nothing is being kept
there's nothing no just the nice stuff
is kept quiet i went out with her yeah i
kissed her on the cheek
down to my hat
yeah uh he just sit there and he'd
always say something funny like a little
it used to look like a like a toad
with it yeah because it was a hell yeah
yeah yeah why a toad that's the ugliest
of all the opinions
and i thought i liked this little guy
this little little shaved yoda
right and then yeah i was immediately
attracted to him you were
yeah i know in a sort of weird
disgusting you know like a road accident
oh you know you know when you used to go
to the library when you're kidding look
at the medical things with the
things that [ __ ] me what's the weirdest
thing that's ever been born and lived
right
and it was it was i thought oh my god
one grew up
right right it's like i don't know why
this happened i'm sorry
no i don't think it's please it's true
it's like when you find a bowel movement
that you can't believe came out of a
person
all your friends yeah but yes as jim
said it's on your chest
okay
turn the heat down just a little try i
turned it up too much it's great yeah
that's really good
oh so yeah that's how i used to think of
you um
but uh now you've blossomed thank you
and i was a sweet boy
a little sweet little dirty boy you were
a little dirty boy
tell ricky about the pool you know games
i used i used to give my friend oral sex
he was like a bully
and uh he i would uh give him okay oh
god i i would give him more i'll tell
the story
you think oh he's likely to be mildly
embarrassing yeah it's not mildly
embarrassing it's always it's not mildly
then you realize it's actually really
harmful and you start really caring as a
person i mean oh my god the trauma
he just rolled his eyes like i was gonna
say oh when he when he baked the cake
and dropped it
right great god yeah right we were uh we
were in the power
i was probably six at this point oh no
how was he though uh 50 no he was
probably about two years old i might
have been eight he was two years older
a year older but he wasn't much he was
one grade ahead of me right uh
and i remember i would grade it he went
great like i was in second house in the
perversion state
[Laughter]
god this guy's good i want to be just
like you
right yeah one day i'll graduate to
having a little kid before
this is right i i i don't even know if i
should be laughing like
oh yeah it's okay he was uh i'm under
the water now but when i get to grade
five i know when do i get the top bunk
right
i'm taking my jacket off i'm sweating
i'm already worried what he's going to
say
but he was he was a buddy like i would
blow him like that's what i would do he
was like
right they this you've got me because
they've got to let me into this world
really gently because that
that it was a buddy i used to blow it
it's not a normal thing you didn't see
that on friends
no yeah it didn't see it look at the
right is going
i thought we could joey and chandler
what was this what are you just buddies
you're just blowing each other away
rachel comes in and goes i i go no no no
no that's not normal they're blowing
buddies like that's what they play
buddies
everybody's got a blueberry his name's
jim
well they started they started blowing
each other in grade school
and no i
because that was one time i would do it
usually in this hallway outside of his
apartment
right but there was an apartment i
thought you said he was eight no well
his family's a partner
he wasn't a homeowner he really made it
big
didn't he he's in it he's in a silk robe
and he's just smoking a cigarette it's
my apartment yeah
yeah right he's his ten-year-old who's
just trying to pay his mortgage
yes i was blowing this real estate
prodigy okay you know he was uh
and we would uh there was a public pool
we had for our apartment complex
so i didn't know like i felt like if i
couldn't see people they couldn't see me
it's like
i don't remember exactly how old it was
but i remember i was under the water he
had me blow him in the pool
right under the water and he pissed in
my mouth
and i remember i came up and i said
we have to process that
he's going to come and say hi can you
read the signs
[Laughter]
i'm going to tell the superintendent
that you urinate
in the ball
that's the whole story i said i came up
and i'm like don't do that again and he
said all right i won't
and i went down and i i blew him again
and he peed in my mouth again
and that was the first time i i ever
remember thinking like oh for me wanted
to say you should go around schools
telling your inspirational story right
yeah hey kids let me tell you about that
don't be conned twice
the lesson to be learned who likes
swimming
well listen up kids this is unbelievable
if he pees in your mouth once he will do
it again
right now right so so this guy is so
there was it was just you were just they
were just um
right and you did this presumably this
wasn't even
was it sexual or just just a fun life
you know what i remember my one friend
my one buddy
[Laughter]
like i was serious as opposed to what
are you gonna say now
what am i gonna make him say i'm raising
oh my god no my one friend
uh we used to blow each other he
actually caught me blowing this other
first kid
he walked in and caught me blowing that
happens
so embarrassing that's actually
why that's why oj killed his wife
because of that because he walked in and
caught me yeah i nearly said allegedly
but yeah you don't have to yeah that's
the last night you know
yeah right so go on then so so
everyone's
what sorry what town was this edison new
jersey edition new jersey so
um all the all the guys that was just a
normal thing was it there everyone
in edison new jersey is calling now
[ __ ] don't don't
dare you say that so yeah so he got
erections and i didn't like i didn't
know what erections were
the first person i ever knew who got him
was this kid who was like a year older
than me different kid than the people
right yeah he showed me what could
happen but i didn't understand like it
felt really good
but i didn't know what that was when it
stood up right i didn't know what it was
okay so right right i'm glad you have
friends there to help guide you through
these the landmines
you're supposed to learn but but but um
treats their own obviously but why was
there was there never girls involved
there oh yeah there were but i
see there was there was more boys but it
was the occasional girl but they were
scarier
they were a little scarier but yeah
there was girls involved sure yeah and
then as i get older i start to have
crushes and
feelings for girls all right okay yeah
and then
how old were you when you've it looks
like you've done
prison for the first 10 years yeah and
then then
it's like the next then the rest of his
life is sort of more normal and free
well
there's a lot of trips back to prison
because it's like a guy is raised in
prison and then he's expected to
acclimate to society
i know exactly what i mean exactly yeah
they created this like this
this amoral thing that would do anything
to survive so what point did you realize
that uh
urine was a good thing i don't know i
don't know when it came back
it made a comeback at one point oh oh
see i'd wonder what you meant but you
mean he's into that now as well
he likes that i have it in a while but
yeah that was something i don't know if
you
do is it just that you just go uh
whatever
i mean you don't see it i'm going oh i
haven't been pissed on for a while do
you i mean you just go
pretty much in those words i mean
i think when you're when you're bringing
somebody over
uh laying out garbage bags across the
floor by
really
this is my urinating room it's like that
scene when in
american psycho when patrick bateman is
clearly inviting somebody over
to murder him there's newspaper all over
the floor
he's got his butcher coat ready to put
on like this is the only intention of
the evening yeah
i did go through a too i can't believe
that
it's a weird thing there's too much
effort there there's a lot of effort
there
yeah there is you're not i mean sure
yeah there's a lot but it's just to kind
of break things up
and that's also part of the excitement
right like as you're getting the
apartment ready you're like oh this is
going to happen this is going to happen
i literally haven't got me apart ready
i couldn't be a serial killer because i
couldn't be bothered right too much
too many little details forget that all
right here's what we're going to do step
one there's steps
i'm not doing that i'm doing that
there's a guy um
uh uh advertised in the paper um
that he wanted to um uh
kill someone and eat them no um
i think it was their testicles was this
the people that actually did wind up
media in germany i think yes yeah
yeah it's like a craigslist type thing
like i'm looking for somebody to kill
and eat
yeah and then slaughter he said they
went to the cinema together didn't they
and then the other guy backed out didn't
they
no well there was one who said looking
for someone to slaughter i believe
was the ad right and they talked for a
while and the one guy went to the other
guy's house
and um he did i think started by eating
the dick and balls and the guy was still
alive in the tub the next day
i don't know if they gave the guy a
murder conviction or something else
because the other guy truly was
volunteering
to be eaten i don't think you can i
don't think you can volunteer to let
someone else commit a crime
i don't think so either there it is i'm
looking for someone to slaughter
inside the world of consensual
cannibalism yeah i don't think
there are certain things you can't
consent to he does what do you know
cannibalism is probably what's
incredible is right again right you're a
cannibal
right okay but he doesn't he doesn't
want to break the law or take a victim
right he thinks i'll just put an eye on
the paper he doesn't want to hurt
anybody's feelings he doesn't want to
like
it's not he doesn't want to hold anybody
against their will i know he looks a
little crazy though
the guy looks a little crazy yeah look
like like that's
of course he looks a little crazy
imagine showing up at that guy's house
and knowing he wants to eat you like
who's the guy that went through it the
other guy who went through it is crazier
than me yeah
i'm eating someone's bad but showing up
and going i'd love to be devoured that's
bad [ __ ] crazy but you know it might be
a thing with cannibals because jeffrey
dahmer who's like probably the most
famous cannibal
he was eating people not many though is
there no there's a smell
it's not a big pool is it just been
voted most famous
centerfold for cannibal magazine again
yeah at least
mom you always told me if i'm going to
do something be the best at it
it's unbelievable well there was a a
mass murderer in england
um uh that uh
beat the record of the guy from the
north right the
i think was it the yorkshire ripper and
then um
it was the guy jane that one with the
the
guy used to uh kill people um
it was the guy from the it was the
yorkshire ripper and anyway someone
uh um some guy from london
and when he was arrested he said at
least i brought the record back to the
south
[Laughter]
like it was like you know like the world
cup
yeah they were waiting for it they were
like i can't believe we lost their oh
good we got it back
yeah so that people do want to be famous
though yeah oh definitely i think they
do want to know it
they want to be where they want to be
the best at something or they want to
have the record
just it is that i was here it really is
that
isn't it like i'd i'll do that that i'll
do anything
well it's the same anyway don't people
do anything to be famous now i mean
within the law
they've realized that they're rewarded
for doing doing terrible things
so i think it is about someone will
notice me i think that's why people
become nazis and they think well at
least i'm something now do you mean
modern-day nazis are back in the day
yeah oh
yeah whether you didn't yeah just so
it's my identity it's a built-in
identity i don't have to search anymore
figure out who i am now i've got love
for my my fellow nazis
people are scared of me or they hate me
but at least they acknowledge me
yeah i'm a nazi and i have a built-in
idea i don't have to think for myself
but i have to go through these ah
good they're all here i know how i feel
about things i know what to wear i know
how to i know how to
be this yeah i've got i'll grow a little
moustache
right now i can do that i can grow
little stars yeah
i saw the white supremacists they're
they're they're not the supreme race
no a lot of them they really don't that
a lot of them are sort of
a bit darkish yeah some of them are not
in the best physical shape
hitler when he wanted like six foot
areas what's going on
look what you did look at you yeah
with black hair right it's like what are
you doing a b-level painter
i know yeah it's weird isn't it it is
strange that
there was a great scene in uh what's
what's the the uh gary oldman churchill
from the longest night or the
no the darkest hour the darkest hour
where he said a house painter
he just he's talking about hitler and he
just snapped and called him a house
painter
like he was like what the [ __ ] are we
doing giving in to a guy who was a
painter
like it just didn't it annoyed him so
much it's that hit there wasn't he saw a
failure all his life
yeah that's what you know didn't get
didn't do that didn't do that over all
this
it's classic but when he succeeded i
mean you got to be honest
yeah we're still talking about him yeah
i know oh i'm
i never stopped talking about him i talk
about on my show
there's a regular question comes up that
used to it annoys me in like um
you know sci-fi when they always go back
and sort of try and kill hitler
and i discuss it there are again but
it's ridiculous to one you don't know
whether that would be for the
girl you don't know what it would change
right also they go back and they they
try and like like
strangle a baby and okay well that baby
hasn't done anything yet
right i mean right like how do you know
also if you can go back
you can change him you can be getting
into a hot glue how about this
just give him a painting scholarship you
don't have to kill him when he's a baby
just make him a painter
yeah yeah and then he's and there's all
he's all lovely well that's that
butterfly effect like you should be able
to just go back in time
yeah change what color shoes he's
wearing that day and be done
it's a nudge you don't have to cha they
say if there's an asteroid coming they
won't have to blow it up they just blow
something up near it and that little
nudge far enough away will get it to
miss the plan
that's what you do it's a little gentle
nudge a little gentle note what would
jim do if he went back in time
the [ __ ] he would do i mean i can't
he'd come back right and everyone would
look like him
he just he just fathered children he
went back really long long way and
just like [ __ ] came on fish right and
then
he just
[Laughter]
oh god it looks like it looks like the
shape of water except it's jim
oh yeah
oh god that'll be amazing oh
yeah i've got those moments where you go
back and go i wish i had done this
yeah there's a couple like what you
don't wish
you didn't wish you were in the 1940s
though no no no no no no
in your own lifetime you'd go back oh
yeah the little things that you're like
let's get the rules right do you go back
and you're
you now right and there's a little gym
somewhere you've got to avoid like in
back to the future right right and you
can you can
you know you can because the space time
contains exactly but you can do stuff
and then you might not be
in all that sort of stuff right or do
you go back and you're sort of a ghost
just watching
just watching [ __ ] and you can't really
interact it's like a rerun
or do you go back right and you're you
in your own head in your own head but
with your with your
future memories which one is it which
one is it probably with my future memory
so i wouldn't know what to avoid like i
would just okay this moment
um
[Laughter]
even if i knew what i knew now i still
probably i would still probably get the
one piss in the mouth but he never would
have got me twice yeah
jim would go back in time and he'd find
little gym and he'd go listen little
jimmy i'm not going to tell you who i am
but let's just say
that a day will come when a boy's going
to pitch it
listen listen listen
listen are you saying little gym when
you're trying to blow a future
just stop i get i get it trust me i get
it
yeah and then and then jim has to go
back to the future and explain to doc
brown who's sitting there like
you didn't interact with your with your
past self did you oh god he
he did blow me once he didn't but that's
against the law
no it's me it's me you finally found a
way to blow yourself
yeah it just took a time machine right
yeah a little weird to say a little
weird nudge
little weird nudges that you go yeah
that would have changed the way i do
certain this or that you know yeah
let's go back to hitler right he's about
he's about 15 right
he's a bit angry right teenage children
he's a bit racist
right just a little a little bit racist
i don't know i don't know how to blame
him you go come here hitler give him a
little hug
he goes oh thank you right and that's it
right
and then now do you wear like a yarmulke
when you give them a hug just so sure
but then you come back to the future
right and stalin's taken over
you right right and there's 300 votes
back let me find the baby starving right
but you've only got three trips in your
time machine so you're like
am i gonna i really gotta not waste
these things anymore
i mean this is like zelig right it
happened but then we're looking through
papers right and all these there's
hitler
stalin chairman mao all being sucked off
by little jim
[Laughter]
machine right and you're like oh maybe i
should go back and just nudge hitler and
then you go
you know i'm gonna actually go back and
see if that gym story was true
yeah i'm just gonna watch somewhere you
would though
there's no way you go back to like big
events no
you get bored with that i would wanna
see exactly nuremberg brothers like
beaudacia i've watched him suck himself
off 30 times
but then you walk in and you see me and
my friend blowing each other you're like
oh my god and then a cop arrests you
and there's no more gervais there's just
some guy that went to jail
he's gonna go back down for a second one
he's got a swear officer no
i i quite like the idea that um
do you have radio awards in america um
there are some i've
certainly never been nominated for
something i think we should just
it's 30 minutes of you sucking people
off including hitler
but that includes time travel and
historical sure it's an interesting
concept
yeah best conceptual hour this is like
an episode of black mirror it sure is
yeah i think so
oh yes except mirror the word mirror be
changed
we've gone through jim's psyche make it
a little cooler here if you're good it's
are you guys still warm thanks buddy i'm
a little warm yeah me too
but maybe it's just all this talk i just
like the tour is ending
pretty much soon i'm going i'm winding
down sorry is this this is not
a mouthful of shame this is no i yeah i
after that came out i just dropped it
and started the new house
yeah i've got to start again now i've
been out uh doing that's been great
yeah i i honestly i i love it more than
anything now i can't wait to start again
when do you when did your uh what does
humanity appear on oh it's tomorrow
oh yeah oh that's awesome i finished it
in amsterdam
um i assume you love amsterdam for
different reasons i've only been once it
was fun
all right yeah no i i think it's
beautiful i ended the tour there i did
did an early one there and i went it's
just just just great in fact
it's so funny because it started off
with me whinging about the world
but then so behind the scenes you
realize what an amazing place the world
is and all these amazing copenhagen
and dams they're just it's just
incredible though what did you do when
you were there did you how many days do
you give yourself to go out and hang out
well it depends
you see on these places i usually do a
big place
go there for two days have one night
after and come back right um
uh but uh i mean me and jane going we
have a bit of a holiday and it's like an
hour and a half on stage and it's great
um that's probably not the most
cost-effective way
to do a tour yeah
you know you you do like 10 weeks of i
have weekends off in england because i
don't like
drunk crowds um oh i prefer the week
yeah i'm i'm talking to them i don't
want i don't want people that went there
because
they had a day off and they add a few
points i want people to go there like a
sort of like you do a a theater
experience or or
a church experience right you know i
want them to work i think this is kind
of
i'm only worshiping you because i've had
a few right i'm gonna go no you worship
me when you're sober
right i get you drunk on love right not
not like jim gets people drunk on love
yes although there's more drinking in my
life
love and urine yeah oh god
oh my god yes so no i absolutely i loved
it
i just i i just i want to be a i just
want to be a stand-up now
and uh before it was like
um like a third or fourth thing i did
but now it's the first thing i did
and and everything else comes next we
talked about you with the oscars with
the way kimmel did it and somebody
raised a good point
that and again kibble i think did the
best job under the circumstance where
jimmy
is playing to the people in the room
where you tend to play the people at
home to the people at home which is why
people love what you're doing
the oscars seems like a tough gig right
now with everything that's been
happening oh listen the oscars is a
tough gig anyway right
listen all award shows are a tough gig
because they're not there to see a
comedian right
they're there right to win an award and
as the night goes on
more people have lost so they're they're
more disgruntled
they're getting drunk they don't they
don't if this is not a good forum for a
comic and they don't want to be made fun
of certainly after
they've lost yeah so you you mustn't do
it for them because they don't
so you've got to do it you've got to
take an opportunity also if they want
mutual backslapping how lovely
everything is fine but don't televise it
i tried to make it a spectator sport i
put
you know 200 people in the room or 200
million people watching around the world
there's no contest i'd do it for them
right
also you've got to be a bit of an
outsider i can't be the lovey
as nauseating do you know what i mean
yeah even though i am in their gang sort
of
i've got to play this um as comedians
we've got to be
we've got to be sort of uncorruptable
for a start we have to know like
there's no we're not beholden to anyone
we mustn't not do a joke because we're
scared
a producer won't like it or a director
so so i don't care about them because i
i write i own my own labor so i've got
you know what i mean i'm not beholden
right so it's fair right i think you
have to punch up you have to go after
nbc that you know bite the hand that
feeds you that's sort of very classic
um and i think that we've got to be low
status
so i can't go up there and say i know
these people or
i'm as rich as these people i've got to
be a slob with a beer do you know what i
mean yeah of course
it's funnier to watch it's more fun to
watch yeah what's the mo have you had
the mel gibson moment was really great
what's the most has there been a moment
where you've done something you've done
a joke in one of those things but you're
like
oh like was there an uncomfortable
moment without no no
there wasn't i i you know i stand by it
all um
there's there's one that's hard to
justify and the only way i can justify
is it was unfortunate right
i know um i did a thing where um
uh tom hanks and tim allen were coming
out to present an award
and so the joke i did i went out with
two cards i said our next two percent
the first
the first one um he's made over five
billion at the box office
he's been in schindler's list he did
the philanthropy just it's really mad
thing
how amazing tom hanks is and i look and
then i go and the other is and i look at
the card and there's nothing on it i go
tim allen
right and that's the gag right and of
course
i found that he didn't like it i don't
want to say say no yeah
he doesn't know me and he took it
personally and and i thought oh
he's sort of right right but my only
defense was
who is going to look good coming out
next to tom hanks
yeah i mean that could have been me it
should have been this exactly the same
joke because meanwhile the joke is it's
a good joke because tim allen
has made hundreds of millions doing
those christmas movies
home improvement but yeah yeah i was in
my story yeah exactly yeah so it it
it only counts because he was next to
tom hanks sure
but also like is your job as the host of
those shows
the whole shows are about putting people
over like you're giving them awards
you're like yes they're so great they're
so great they're so great
is your job as a host really to like get
them over more like to just keep
consistently being like these guys are
great these guys what exactly
are you supposed to do but but no one
wants to be about the joke and so in all
other jokes i think that i can
you know i don't go after people's i
don't go after things that they can't
help
right but i do go after their public
behavior but i think that was the odd
one out
because i made it look like he was a
total failure
and he but he isn't it's like it's like
people would
people no one thought yeah rick's right
tim allen's done
nothing right he's the worst he got the
joke yeah yeah did he get a laugh
no i didn't like it so i wasn't guilty
he didn't like it i was sort of guilty
that he was sort of right
that um he didn't deserve it but no one
did
yeah i'm saying it was just a joke it
was versus tom hanks shortest actor
and it was just you know i'd have done
it to a friend yeah in fact
that would have been more justified but
no there's nothing i
you know it it could have been almost
anybody at that
show next to tom hanks i think so it
would have been a similar joke well
exactly that yeah it would be better if
it wasn't a fellow actor
right it would have been better if it
was ryan seacrest who's not in the game
and just you know i
yeah well he's in terms of stand up
though like he became an actor and he
became more but
i think still think there's a funny joke
i think he's the perfect guy to do it
because you're hitting a guy but you are
hitting a guy who everyone knows has
made hundreds of millions yeah so it's
almost like you can't feel bad for them
i think the problem is
what people don't realize is is is how
fragile these actors are
they're precarious they they pick up
symptoms you know
those stories of measuring the the uh
you know the winnebago is true
that is true well they they measure the
that you know they
they have things like and and i know i
know it's not them
they measure their trailers and they
they have to
have equity and like i have to get one
pound more than the next person it's all
it's all these games that that makes
them think that they're
they're still relevant and important and
they want to be in that you know
and it doesn't mean anything because you
could measure you get the top
you know 50 top actors in the world
right and it is
i'm talking about actors now because
it's different with everything else
really
um and that you asked people who's the
top i said what you
what are you judging it by um total
income ever
this year um kudos uh you know it's it's
it's crazy to try and say who's the
because so so what they'd end up doing
is they just do
highest fee and highest paid and they
manipulate that to
and they then they release it right you
know what i mean
yes it's what the public is releasing
once you once you've started that game
you're hooked because then next year
you're second and then you're fourth and
then you're out
it's like you got you're done you know
it's like
i was the fourth number four i mean
there's so many people who want to be
actors i think it's because they
feel they don't own their own labor that
they're at the mercy of
being cast and having you know is that
why you you like
stand up so much because like you start
doing it and you're like wait a minute
this is just
i mean i i i i can't wait to get back
because even if you get final edit and i
do on all my stuff i always have from
the office
every every film every tv show but
there's still
60 people involved right whereas this is
i
i do it to go on holiday i can sell out
an arena just because i wanted to visit
that place and have
two days off it's it it's incredible
i do the same thing except that when i'm
getting three days off when they cancel
the show
but it is like being a genie uh what's
your wish i want to go here on a play i
want to say
it's incredible and there's there's
nothing else like that you can't do that
film i want to film it here they go
there's no tax breaks we can't
i'll forget it right whereas i literally
do what i want without breaking
the laws of the there's no land
it's you know overhead it's like if
there was anybody else and also and
that's why i think that's why
people started saying like um you know
standup was the new rock and roll
yeah i thought it meant because it was
like the glamour or the you know like
they were doing drugs or whatever right
it's not that i think it's because
you're yourself like rock and roll stars
are
because when you're an actor you dress
up in a rubber suit and you're in a big
film and everyone loves you
when you're not in that film you do your
own film about a terrible cancer like no
one goes to see it i don't know
it was the rubber suit we liked mate
right you know what i mean anyone anyone
could be that
there are actors that are literally like
they're known for something yeah and
then they'll go off and do their own
project and then when it comes time to
do interviews and stuff they'll go okay
you can ask two questions about the
other stuff
and then the rest has to be about the
new project oh it's horrible and you're
like where's your treadmill yeah
they don't want to you see they want to
die right and it's like it's like it's
not them
it's not there's not them they they know
that another actor could have done it
whereas with stand-up you're
you're even though you're saying
terrible things it might be a persona
you're that person on stage when you get
off stage you're that person you're that
person they saw on stag
and i think that's that's something and
that's like a rock star nobody else is
going to perform as ricky gervais doing
stand up and if they can then you should
look at your material if someone else
can do your material you should re-look
at your material you're taking shots at
gallagher
there was the gallagher two his mother
went out and toured his bro he was like
a prop comic
in like the 80s and his brother who
looks like him
just started touring his gallagher and
he's called gallagher
that's really unfortunate and it became
but it was yeah
it got ugly after a while um yeah it did
get like ryan he was the guy who would
break the watermelon he was actually a
good comic i mean he
he was oh he hit a bunch of specials he
was very prolific right uh he kind of
became the punch line of galileo because
the name gallagher but he did a lot of
topical material and he worked for years
and years and years he was very
successful
but then gallagher to his brother who
looks like him when gallagher's
quote-unquote retirement went out and
started doing his material
right same act same i think he's just as
good just because he
did see how to do it no it's different
yeah he's different yeah
i think i knew i worked with gallagher
too once years ago my open forum
i mean i think the idea is in in this is
that you want to be
you want to be essential yes you know
what i mean yes you wanna
it's like i don't that's why i don't i
play i don't like
i don't like the fact that they said
well i was going to go and see a
comedian this year
might as well go and see this one i want
to go no they they they went to the
ricky gervais
yeah yeah and you do that as well you
play like if you play a town
and you play um uh you set out three
three arenas in that town right and the
the promoter says oh my god we could do
a fourth
you do a fourth and it doesn't go in two
minutes it doesn't go into it
it took about a week or three weeks
right so then
that fourth night is the people who
didn't really care about seeing you they
could get a ticket
so i try and i try never to do that
fourth
cut it off before a show absolutely so
that everyone at that gig
yes should [ __ ] i do that as well
except it won't be the second gig what
i'll do is i'll have to put a curtain in
the middle of the room
you know what i mean
if you if you can sell out a gig in
three minutes don't put another one on
that takes a week to sell do you know me
but you're talking about
stopping selling tickets and jim's
talking about when tickets stop selling
yeah yeah
this is a tremendous difference yeah but
it suddenly made me look like i was
saying this is
like anyone could do this but actually
but i don't have to i don't i don't have
to because
luckily because of the office next door
or anything else right
i can sort of i can play more places so
i don't have to
i don't have to prise the money out of
one place
most of the people a lot of people with
the option might take the option of just
doing as many shows as humanly possible
and getting all the money
and i get that because some people that
you know it's the one thing they do as
well
and uh they might be big in one country
so of course they should
of course they why wouldn't they right
it's just that it sort of spoils it for
me
i like that i like the thrill of it
still i don't i don't like just going
around collecting money it's like
i love the fact that every kick's really
great and interesting and
you have new stuff that you're working
on now
yeah already how much stuff do you have
i've got a i've got a
um enough to start warm-ups so if you
you have enough to go out and do
45 minutes or an hour or whatever well i
have enough to do
three or four bad seven-minute
things yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't i
wouldn't i wouldn't subject him to a
big chunk of it yet because it's all me
looking at notes and going
what do you think of this i hook up a
gopro when i do it every night i have a
gopro
and it gives you a decent quality just
go home and watch it if you want all
right well i
what i what i started doing right um
because i can't really
it i can't pay sort of clubs and focus
it doesn't give me the right atmosphere
because i don't do that
sort of thing and the pressure's on as
well and now with people on [ __ ]
youtube
i can't even try something that fails
anymore because you know what i mean
you don't get the chance to do it my
warm up for my
my previous thing science right the
biggest newspaper was in
on the first gig i ever did right they
said it was all right
but don't i mean [ __ ] me you're like
warming up in the art and the thing
he's been warming up gervase has lost it
i know he's not funny anymore
yeah so what i do now is i hire a little
theater the one you played leicester
square sure
and i go three chums so i go out and i
go oh this is gonna and they do their
bits
and i walk out and i've i do four sort
of like five minute bits then i drop one
of the
chums and i do two and then i get down
to one then it's just no that's a great
way to do it okay yeah
you take one guy evening the pressure's
off they know everyone's trying out
stuff
there's not a there's not 20 minutes of
him struggling
i've come out i you know do it and do
you go on to new york at all though you
do you just never have i
really really want to you should yeah
it's just never give me something else
i'm thinking about doing warm-ups in
europe so i might as well
you know so you don't have to announce
it you just go down and you go on you do
10 minutes
if like a seller or something yeah yeah
that's what jerry seinfeld does that's
what all of them do they just go on
try it out sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't people are used to it did you
the big lesson i learned this time and
this shouldn't be a revelation
at 56 right is that
um the first four i sort of wrote you
know like edinburgh shows and then i
went and sort of rehearsed them like an
actor
right and this time i walked out and
just started talking which is
the way i assume a lot of comedians do
yeah and
um it's ten times better because you
don't stage time is worth
ten times writing time it absolutely is
it's crazy i thought
any new eyes i'd say don't even bother
writing
go out and talk every night just talk
every night until someone laughs
writing it down helps just for memory
purpose because my memory is so awful
but just trying it and then going oh
that feels better that feels better and
then i'll have to like look at my phone
once in a while or take out a paper but
yeah i would much rather work it on
stage but i can't write the whole thing
down
and then just do it no and uh you end up
with the
same place i guess because the audience
are eventually choosing your
your show for you which i love i love
that now i i again i used to
i used to be intimidated by that you
know i felt guilty about laughs
i thought oh that's not they laugh but
it's not a great joke
oh if they laughed or something you
didn't think you know what i mean you
can do it you can do it with it you can
make them laugh with enthusiasm
yeah right i mean you can make them
laugh by jumping around
yeah that's what i'm going to call my
new special exclamation point
every joke i deliver with pepe yeah yeah
deliver it deliver it stand forward you
know yeah a lot of people have come out
of uh
gym shows and the reviews have said
already they know you're lying
[Laughter]
it means halfway through they say he
prowls the stage like a panther
oh yeah i i actually fed them that line
oh you did oh yeah
yeah that's great laundering your quotes
is great isn't it
it's great i saw jim once uh it was he
was doing it
like it was an extra gig on the tour so
he'd already filmed this special
and he decided it was the new year's gig
in westchester oh that's not what the
people were the [ __ ] infant
yeah they brought they first of all
somebody brought others that's
unacceptable
to jim show but jim was just in such a
goofy mood
and he'd already filmed the special so
he like the the material wasn't exciting
him anymore
he just started walking around the stage
back and forth just throwing the
microphone back and forth to himself
going
huh it was so much [ __ ] fun
so silly it's in a theater and
especially it was filming it
no no it was after i've been oh you've
done it
i saw the infant walk in and i'm like oh
boy i mean you know
be careful yeah i'm like oh boy he's
gonna get pissed up there because i've
you know i've seen jim get pissed at
stuff before he could have cared less he
thought it was funny because he did not
care i'd never take a day off being
annoyed at that
it wouldn't matter the kid was quiet
though i could have i could have just
been told you know
uh that i mean i'm not gonna die after
all i could have been thinking i was
gonna die for you and i said no you're
totally cured and that baby looked like
i've still been [ __ ] angry
well good news yeah yeah
yeah oh oh my god i was really annoyed
when i saw it and i was just sitting in
the audience
i vaguely yeah i do remember that she
was so easily annoyed because i want
everything to be perfect
right you know what i mean everything's
i plan everything to just be just right
people just act the way people are
supposed to act everything will go
according to plan
uh well i i did a uh like three weeks at
hammersmith apollo right
and uh the first night i could hear sort
of thump and i said oh yeah because it's
on this and
um under the floor is where they keep
the cables
so i had them sort of like put carpet on
that then those doors were squeaking so
i had them oiling the doors
then the security guards were wearing
yellow so i had them put in black
because i didn't want to sit
honestly it was distraction after
distraction just it got just about right
by the time i filmed
ocd absolutely yeah but that is the most
that is the time i was it because
anything can put me on because something
even if um even film if i think filming
on ocd because you sort of want it to be
perfect sure
and i'm thinking about that so um but
i'd say i'm the worst
i'm the worst in the theater but didn't
you say you walked out of a restaurant
because
you yelled [ __ ] or something because
some guy was being a [ __ ] because he was
eating loud or doing something yeah we
were going faster
last time we were here we were going
past the restaurant in the car
and i said to jane oh oh look at that
that's a nice restaurant
she was yeah we went there once um we
had to leave because she said some [ __ ]
was eating bread
but um oh my god where was that place
was that was it in san francisco that
restaurant
oh no the oh [ __ ] me right so we're in
this nice restaurant
right okay so we're the only day we got
there and it was lovely right it's
lovely empty
perfect right right in the corner right
great right
our way it comes our weight is great as
well it's lovely right
and then there's a i assume the busboy
someone he comes out
right and it's across the room and i
hear him do this
[Music]
i go [ __ ] no
like that right right he said he goes
right away it comes over oh god i'm
sweating i'm thinking i'm going to do it
i can't move because
i'm i'm as far away as i can be from him
right he goes away and come back and
jamie
don't worry about it comes out again he
comes out from his little holes
i'm going i'm going crunk like that
right she's going to kind of go [ __ ] me
what am i going to do what am i going to
do i'm going to tell him
you can't
every time i think okay the food's gonna
come and i'm gonna take the mouthful and
i know
and honestly i i ate the food so fast so
he didn't come out and go
like that does it gross you out or is it
a sound issue
right right okay there's right many
things right it grosses me out right it
grosses me out right
genuinely that's the first thing that's
why i hate that right right but it's the
[ __ ]
it's not even the arrogance because it
doesn't know he's doing it it's the lack
of awareness
of anyone doing it right i i [ __ ]
build her doing it annoys me right right
but a bloke working in a restaurant
people are eating
has no one ever said mate you disgusting
[ __ ] don't do that again or you're fired
right and your children will die right
right
i i i don't know that these are lessons
that should be taught in childhood
honestly well some of us are busy in
childhood that's true
you can't the problem is you can't hear
underwater
so yeah i i it's why and
i'll be in a restaurant and someone
would like be uh having an
annoying voice just being human just
talking to someone right
and i'll be staring at them and jane's
going i don't know why you're staring at
them
right like like i'm going to look at
them and they go oh i see my voice isn't
that good yeah
sorry okay but i want them to know
right i want them to know why they've
never been told they've got an annoying
voice right
they need to be if they're going to
speak in a public place it needs to be
very quiet i want some sort of etiquette
morality police just someone there
someone does that and they get a slap
immediately they get slapped
right he's just there like there's a
slap oh sorry what was it it was the
oh sorry i'm sorry i'll never do that
again i'll never do that again light
hitting should be okay